This year I competed in the British Sumo
Federation Nationals. In this video I'll
show you all my bouts and I'll also
explain how I ended up like this. I've
been doing sumo for about a year now and
this is my second competition. The rules
of sumo are fairly simple. Either push
your opponent out of the ring or throw
them to the ground. You can also lose by
touching the ground with any part of
your body besides the soles of your
feet. The tournament is double
elimination, meaning once you've lost
twice, you're out.
This is my first battle of the
competition competing in the lightweight
category.
to real.
[Applause]
So, that's my first win with a throw
into a push out.
This is my second bout with Dan, who's
an experienced judoka,
Sweet.
[Music]
Well done.
[Applause]
So with that throw, I managed to secure
a win in the similar way to the first
bout.
This is my third bout with Rob. I lost
to him last year, so I knew it'd be a
tough match.
Your tail
Good.
And this is the point where I land on my
neck.
[Music]
[Applause]
This is my first loss with the wing
going to Rob.
[Applause]
At this point, we're the only ones left
with one loss each. Therefore, it means
it needs to go to a decider for the
final.
It might not be that noticeable, but I'm
in quite a lot of pain. But the
adrenaline's carrying me through.
Okay,
as there's no submissions in Sumo, I
couldn't finish the choke, so I had to
drive Rob back out the ring for the win.
[Applause]
Please your men's lightweight results
are bronze green silver Rob Godfrey gold
Alex Jens.
We will start the men's middleweight in
five minutes.
Before
I had any time to rest, I was back in
fighting first in middleweight.
[Music]
My neck, if anything, was getting worse
and the pain was now radiating down my
right side.
My first battle was against Damian,
who's heavier and got more sumo
experience than me.
Watch
your switch.
[Applause]
I managed to put up a fight but lost the
bout.
My next opponent was Cameron, who I
didn't get a chance to go up against in
my weight category.
The battle was over pretty quickly with
me pushing him out for the win.
Once again, I was next up against Rob.
Sweet.
[Applause]
This win was similar to most my other
wins, using the same structure and
principles to get the throw.
In the next bout, I was facing Damian
again, who had lost one of his matches.
Whoever loses this will be knocked out.
My team.
Hey, let's go.
Dig, dig, dig, Alex. Dig.
Hey. Hey. Now.
[Applause]
I'm not sure what happened there. I was
close to throwing him. However, my leg
gave way at the last moment. This meant
I'd lost the bout and had been knocked
out progressing further. I was due to
fighting open weight as well. However,
my injury was getting worse. So, I
thought I'd do the sensible thing and
drop out. I was happy with getting
golden lightweight, but I was concerned
about my injury.
Two days later, I decided to go to the
hospital and after several X-rays and an
MRI scan, it turned out luckily my neck
had just been strained. However, they
did find that I had fractured my ribs
and sternum. I hadn't even noticed this
initially. It could have happened when I
injured my neck or perhaps during one of
my other two losses in middleweight.
Either way, it's good that I quit when I
did, otherwise things could have got
much worse. I was told I need to rest it
for 6 weeks and so far it's healing
pretty well. Lastly, I just want to give
a shout out to the lads over at Barnsley
Sumo for being great training partners
and helping me progress this year. And
to Richard, my coach, for all his
knowledge and skills that he shared,
which I believe helped me secure my
wins. Anyway, I hope you all found this
interesting. Any questions, leave them
down below. And until next time, take
care.